[Music]
[Music]
Giovana up in the house gucci gang son
Gucci carrying even text Gucci kickin me
out here did it it's good to be hey man
this is the gayest little microphone it
feels like it's all up in your grill oh
it feels like a1 like I'm the weakest
one armed black kid is trying to give me
a hug it feels like they're like you
know like like whoa somebody feed this
boy and then bring him back to the hug
ring you know cuz he ain't ready for
[ __ ] real too long this dude ain't
ready hug him with one arm did I
remember being at the library when I was
young and this is back when they had
books you know what do they have now um
you know I mean I'm reckon [ __ ] I know
our library's still open who's hitting
here cuz peoples around a finger each
other
yeah man open this app anybody else from
the south back yeah second place in the
Civil War
Ronna Rock Isaac Newton had this theory
of gravity in motion but I I'm Stein's
the guy who figured out the time and
spaces of fabric oh and that gravity
bends it like he just was this guy was
so brilliant he sat in his office and he
was having a thought experiment and he
imagined the more mass you had the more
you bended this fabric of space and it's
[ __ ] crazy that's crazy imagine didn't
go into telling somebody command to tell
your neighbor that yeah bro where's
Larry I liked him better yeah I just saw
a guy outside of the DSW shoes and he
bendin space and yeah imagine what he
you think he [ __ ] like awesomely or
you think that was like he [ __ ] nasty
it one's really nasty science play not
that there's not attractive science
girls no but I mean I think he was like
you know like a basic kind of sexual guy
you think he was like doing wild stuff
in equations he was like let me yeah why
don't we just drop me from a hundred
feet in China you know if you want to do
that I wish I knew my dad was old man my
dad was 70 years old when I was born
Wow is that right thank you for laughing
at my daddy my mom was 32 which
basically makes me a product of loose
skin and loose morals
here but it was cool though like the
quality time we would spend like after
after I was born my dad had a stroke so
we were both learning to walk at the
same time we'd have like little races
for cookies you know and we play games
like catch or dull and my favorite is
that sleeping where is he no longer with
us
Dutch are so aerodynamic they move good
you know you ever seen a Dutch that
really are dynamic there then what what
are you doing you're lean face lean
headed four inches cheek to cheek or big
people
dude dude how big they're the DOTC oh
they're very tall but they're very
aerodynamic very aerodynamic the
downhill people they call him dude look
it's pull up a Dutch girls really big
small sleeping
who hasn't dated a lazy eye girl for a
little bit don't laugh man she's a hell
of a skeet shooter that's my favorite
joke man I used to get mad and get up in
her face and go pull and just watch rock
that's my favorite joke man I like to
date a homeless lady man cuz after the
date you could just drop her off
anywhere but I like I like strong girl
you know I like a sturdy gal man you
know kind of girl you know get into some
things you know I mean these skinny
girls man like making love to a can of
pick-up sticks you know I'm serious mass
like making love to a pillowcase full of
deer antlers
no I need a girl that's got some owner
you know maybe a little decent in the
pan kind of girl it'll just snatch a
goat off a bridge if she has to gets in
or some thing you know what him thank
these these skinny girls just don't do
it for me man
you knew yeah she's got a speech
impediment she does this a lot if she
can cook I won't say I'm serious serious
Michael a lot of women don't cook
anymore man and here's my thoughts true
gentleman here that hunger clapping
here's my thoughts ladies if God didn't
want you to cook then why did he
naturally put milk and eggs in your body
[Applause]
you know you put you are you a porno guy
looks like redtube or whatever the [ __ ]
you say I've been out there man I've
been in the it's nasty out there it is
nasty dude it was just talking about
this on my podcast it's nasty some of
these videos and people doing all these
blood activities and everything and but
you know the thing you are like you just
gotta it's constantly escalating like
everyone's trying to one-up each other
in the porn and I don't want to be in it
they are aren't they
it's just thr I don't need seven guys
know what happened just one on one it's
on why why does it have to be a game
being everything yeah yeah and it's so
rough whack Amole to if you see
someone's gangbangs they get stuck
it's like urban whack-a-mole in Andrew
Santino has the best he talks about how
a lot of black gentlemen always have
their sneakers on during the pornography
regrip used to really rail at home rip
and probably its foot is rampant and
also I don't know who the [ __ ] been on
this carpet he goes back to
indoor/outdoor like those are kind of
outdoor shoes and they have one indoors
full circle with Theo von and I don't
care about the French dude Wow but you
have you been there you just didn't
register I'd you this - how you been a
friends yeah you been a Montreal I've
been a Montreal yo you didn't love the
French I love the Canadians French
Canadians yeah I'll take them you love
Canadians period I love Canadians period
but do you love French Canadians yes
because they are Canadian but French bro
not into French and nobody is they make
great wine yes I true people go to Paris
every year
yeah but they leave it's not the kind of
place people are milling around man
black people don't really know they
don't differentiate between indoors and
outdoors
booty's can be indoors dude what do you
mean outdoors can be indoors black
person you can put them outdoors and you
put them indoors same volume levels same
speed there's no inside voice there's no
there's zero and snow edit kill he going
to loose well they just don't know how
to [ __ ] I don't believe in I like a lot
of structures and I don't know if I
don't want to say woodwork but I
say over all that they the difference
between indoors and outdoors when it
comes from mostly it's so incredibly
vaguely racist do you think there's more
porn stars or murders in the world hmm
I think murders you know I actually know
a guy I shouldn't say this on here but
I'm not gonna say names but I know a guy
who killed someone and he said and this
isn't me saying this dude I wouldn't do
something like this but he said that it
[ __ ] feels good the Koreans are full
of dreams man yeah we saw this asian guy
could have been Korean he was fell off a
building when he hit the bottom
huh dreams came out of him bro but
dreams doing guts and blood no I just
mean you could just feel the [ __ ]
fragments of ideas and hope and
imagination fly out of his body hey I
want to thank everybody from fighter in
the kid you know I was a and that's a
podcast where they have this man who is
a fighter
and he got he got beat up and he got
attacked a couple times and he couldn't
fight anymore because his brain couldn't
handle it he was on the brisk of freakin
getting that you know a brush with that
tis 'm and so his brain you know told
him we got to shut it down and so he
quit fighting and he met up with this
other man who's kind of aging but he's
just you know a sweet funny guy and got
strong legs the other guy and their
names are Brendan and Brian in the
podcast is called the fighter and the
kid and one of them uses moisturizer and
one of them needs moisturizer